你在这里一年挣18万，
你付出的时间、
精力和心血是多少，
你去他那个小公司，
你想要挣20万，
你所付出的时间力、
心血你自己预判一下也是多少。
假咨询医师，
关于工作我想让您帮我分析一下，
因为这个事情我思考了好几天，
但是我身边没有一个比较亲近的人，
认职高的人帮我去分析一下，
我目前在的这家公司是已经干了七年了，
是大一点的公司吧，
我觉得我现在是可以看到头了，
也是是一个瓶颈期吧，
这个时候正好有一个前同事，
他原来是跟我们是在一个单位的，
他现在自己出去开了公司，
开了有两三年，
现在他业绩是因为品喷式增长，
就需要人，
他就邀请了我，
跟我大概聊了一下，
待遇来讲的话，
跟这边工资到手候基本上是不变，
现在的单位目前扣除五险一金的话，
到手差不多是18万这样子，
他让我过去的话，
到时候就是说扣除五险金话保底20万，
因为他那边属于那种私人单位，
有过去相当于有一个小职务的这种感觉，
除了我公资跟年终奖之外，
年底的话会跟业绩也会有挂钩嘛，
再有点小提成，
我想说说我去跟不去的理由吧，
你帮我们分析分析，
从内心。
分数来讲，
我是有一点想去的，
因为目前的这种我所在的单位环境，
我的领导明面上其实都是挺好的，
但是他私下有跟我聊过天，
我觉得他可能对我现在目前的工作方式有点不太认可，
他觉得我现在的工作有点问题，
他也在跟我讲年前的话，
他跟我呃聊过天，
意思就是说如果今年我的工作如果还是没有得到改善的话，
可能就会给我去调岗，
他明确跟我说，
如果是进行调岗的话，
可能我的工资待遇是不会变的，
他说就看我今年的一个表现吧。
还有第二个原因就是我觉得我现在在这个单位干了这么多年，
再往后去看，
我觉得我的发展是可以看到的，
这个就是我想走的，
我不想走的原因就是因为在这边已经干了7年了，
因为我是从工作到现在7年了，
我没有去看过外面的一些，
没有招聘信息，
我也不知道外面的一个环境是怎么样的，
突然一下子离开这个环境，
但然的新的环境，
我有点忐忑。
第二个比如说现在这种单位可能就属于那种旱涝保收，
饿不是也，
也发不了财，
比较相对稳定，
如果换了的话，
我也不确定因素，
你跟我说一下你现在的婚恋情况，
你现在是多大年纪，
家庭情况怎么样，
有没有要小孩儿的打算，
还是说已经有小孩了，
大概是个什么情况，
我现在是已婚，
有3岁的宝宝，
目前是。
只有一个男孩子，
我跟我老公年收入两个加起来差不多三十几万，
目前成本是有70万，
没有房贷，
有车贷是两年。
你自己是属于那种事业心很强的人吗？
很希望自己在事业上就像一个头狼一样，
带着几个团队的朋友去，
事业上能有更大的发展吗？
你自己是属于这样的人吗？
我觉得我属于比较有冲锋陷阵的人，
带我在前面，
我属于比较稳定，
给回复后方的那种。
那我觉得你不太适合去小公司，
因为小公司的话，
一旦他发现你来了之后，
并没有真正的拓展疆土，
发挥不了什么太大的边际价值的话，
他分分钟炒了你，
真的，
因为人性都是相通的，
如果你是当老板的，
你挖了一个人过来，
你是希望这个人为我开疆拓土，
你是希望这个人给我挣钱的，
他是把你挖过去了之后，
发现你并没有给他开疆拓，
并没有给他业务上带来更大的边际效益的话，
分分钟开了。
你对这个我也有这样担忧，
他也在跟我聊，
他想让我过去，
他属于你刚刚说的那种类型嘛，
有事业平衡那个东西，
他那边现在的团队构架也是有冲锋现接的人，
相当于他现在接了很多订单，
但是没有人去维护这些订单，
所以他想要找一个这样子的类型的人。
还有一种呢，
就是你在这里一年挣18万，
你付出的时间、
精力和心血是多少？
少，
你去他那个小公司，
你想要挣20万，
你所付出的时间、
精力、
心血，
你自己预判一下也是多少，
因为我现在的这个时间上来讲，
其实也蛮长的，
这边亲卖的领导也是在从大方向讲的话，
尽量在给我们减负嘛，
我也在想，
如果到新的一个环境的话，
前一段时间我肯定会比现在可能是要很忙，
但是对于后面的情况我有点未知，
你现在这个公司大概多少人啊？
本公司来讲的话，
我们可能是差不多有七八百号人，
我们这种类型下面就相当于被承包，
这样总公司下面有个分公司，
我们分公司下面可能有个五六十号人，
我们一个小科室就是十来个人，
那这个公司有国资背景吗？
有，
反正你问我了，
我的态度我觉得还是求稳，
尤其是有了家，
有了小孩之后，
求稳供你参考，
我想呢，
我现在已经是36岁了，
按正常逻辑来讲，
应该是比较稳嘛，
因为我现在的领导可能年前跟我聊的这些，
即使对我现在再不满意，
哪怕今年再不满意，
他只是会调岗，
也不会说是对呀，
因为是国服背景一般，
没有说什么大的问题，
谁也不愿意创这个黑脸的开人，
对，
因为我也不是于一个不太轻易会换工作的人，
我就想着到这个年纪我要不要再撑一把好坏，
这个结果自己来承担，
所以就有点纠结，
以我接触了上万个人性格来说的话。
我不认为你是属于那种冲一把的性格，
好，
就这样啊好，
拜拜啊，
记得点赞关注哦。